hello everyone I'd like to welcome our
next speaker
Bartek will schinsky who flew all the
way from Europe he will be talking about
using understanding your data with
Bayesian networks and he has been
working on high-throughput data analysis
ever sent his work since his work in the
last national Lawrence Livermore Lab
working on DNA sequences analysis and
since 2008 he has been involved in the
development of bien finder a Python
software for finding the structure of
Bayesian networks for machine learning
purposes he holds a PhD in mathematics
and it's the assistant professor of
computer science in the university of
warsaw so let's welcome
Bartek thank you hello you can can you
hear me yeah ok good thank you very much
it's it's been a nice meeting although I
have to say that's a little bit outside
of my natural habitat which is mostly
either at the university or at a
scientific meeting so I actually have to
say that I very much enjoy and I've
already learned many things that current
versions of software it seems the more I
am mmm
the more I'm teaching programming to
users or statistical data analysis
either the more I'm depending on older
versions of packages and it's kind of
cool to to see those kind of
bleeding-edge live demos of things that
have been written written very recently
so what I'm going to talk to you about
today is is actually so I've changed it
the title of the talk a little bit and
I've changed the slides even more after
I've heard a few talks so I'll try to
like to start with a little bit of a so
I'm I understand it not everybody is
familiar with Bayesian networks so I'll
give you intro into into basically what
is this all about so to start you off
like I was wondering what to start with
and naturally xkcd is is something that
is
a very nice thing it always has a comic
about about something I need to talk and
one thing is that with Bayesian
statistics there's a lot to do with with
causation and and and correlation and
and causation is a difficult concept and
this is why I wanted to start here with
we're thinking about confusion so to get
to you a little bit more confused than
you are now I'd like to to maybe bring a
bit of information about teaching so
this is it's always when you think about
teaching about conveying difficult
concepts to people who are not
necessarily not necessarily very
familiar very very much into this you
may wonder how to actually best do it
and and press the buzzer in in in
Harvard has been teaching physics which
is also many many students find
difficult and he was studying what are
the different things that make make
students learn better or worse and he
was asking them questions giving them
showing them a experiment asking them in
a questionnaire different things and one
things he found is that confusion seemed
to be helping so just let's look at the
data it's not too much of data it's
actually eight numbers but it's it's
misleading actually if you know that the
first and second column sum up to one
you'll actually notice there's only four
numbers but it's easy to understood two
different experiments when he asked
students whether they were confused
while while he explained the experiment
to them and then ask them some question
about the experiment those who were
confused tend to I mean it seems that
the questions weren't very easy because
either way majority got the answer wrong
but those that were confused were
actually answering slightly better than
those that are not so you think like
what is the model how do I understand
this data like what is it telling me and
and one very simple model so the model
on the left is basically the simpler
version so it tells you if a student is
confused then he or she is getting the
the
being confused itself must be helping in
understanding or maybe there's an
alternative explanation so maybe we're
not with our data frame or our data set
is not telling us everything maybe and
that's my favorite explanation of this
particular finding is that maybe there's
some hidden variable like for example
whether a student was paying attention
or not so for example if you look at the
right-hand side there's this model wood
which basically includes the additional
variable which is a student being paying
attention paying attention or not and
naturally to be confused you need to pay
attention if you don't pay attention
you're just watching the birds out of
the window and most likely you're not
being confused by by the explanation and
then if you're not paying attention
you're also less likely although well
this depends also on the speaker skills
but you're also less likely to give a
correct answer and then these are just
cartoon models but they're helpful so
you like one key thing is the intuition
is here that that we will think about
variables so things that describe our
observations we describe those
observations in envira balls and then
this kind of act of connecting them with
edges it's somehow intuitively
corresponding to what's causing what
although it's a very high level now and
we just joined these two cartoons it's
very hard to say whether you know
whether one is true or the other is true
I think actually confusion is helping
people think about things and basically
make them make an effort which is why
I'm trying to basically start you off
with something completely irrelevant for
the rest of the talk bit but mmm
basically what I'll try to tell you in
in the rest of the talk is how to
basically move from kind of drawing
cartoons in having intuitive
understanding of of concepts such as
causation to more quantitative models
such as biased networks so what would I
mean by data I'm actually coming from an
computational biology field but I'll
show you some examples of the
education that we have been working on
later but for the purpose of making this
sort of common ground you can imagine
just a questionnaire that a doctor or is
giving to his patients in a hospital or
in a private practice and there's some
data that that we have about different
people it's kind of I have a pointer I
probably could use it or but it's kind
of tricky to show on both strings at the
same time we were still waiting for this
technology that will allow us to point
to one and then give you a kind of a
mirror image of the of the pointer on
the other one but basically each row
corresponds to a patient or a person and
then each column corresponds to some
piece of data about this person or a
variable that could be missing variable
data which I won't go into into now but
it's also possible to handle missing
data with these techniques that I taught
no tell you about so basically we have
this kind of tabular data it's a kind of
very very common I don't think that I
should spend too much time on that and
now what we want to have is some sort of
a network of connections and and this is
again at this intuitive level where I
have those errors just pointing like
saying for example that with increasing
age the chance of having heart problems
is increasing in general statistically
speaking that's something that we kind
of see but it's also for example having
a stressful job or would also have some
influence on the same variable so in
principle one thing that I want you to
think a little bit about is that the
arrows here are kind of intuitively I
think there's not much people don't have
an issue with with the fact that we have
those arrows with a with a mm so there's
basically an orientation in this
influence but most of those errors if
you think long enough about them they
actually
that they're not as easy to draw as you
think so for example let's take this
kind of stressful job too hard leading
to heart problems so it's mmm it's
actually shown scientifically that
having extensive exposure to stress can
cause your problems but then once you
have those problems you're more likely
to change your job to something less
stressful right and if you actually look
at the statistical data of many patients
if you are if you're looking at someone
in an advanced age for example with
heart problems then actually the chance
that they will still be doing their
stressful job are less likely so usually
if you mmm if you look deeply in your
data then there will be also some
additional maybe unexpected connections
it might make things more difficult for
a data analyst there's trying to look at
this and find them out from the data so
kind of sorry for this slide I it's a
bit text-heavy but but basically there's
a few things that you need to know about
bayesian networks - so this previous
slide was kind of a very very abstract
and and intuitive hopefully but but
basically we're talking about a
mathematical object so so what we have
for a Bayesian network it's it's a graph
like the one I showed you it's just one
assumption it's quite technical and it
happens to be important is that it
doesn't have cycles and as I just told
you
in reality it's they're very hard to
meet assumption because usually when
something one thing in influences the
other then you will also see a
reciprocal connection and then sorry
nodes will represent random variables as
we saw and edges between those nodes
represent dependencies and these
dependencies are again causality is a
separate thing we will actually not
address it too much but that dependency
is a simple fact that you will have a
statistical dependence between between
the two variable variables each edge
will be directed from a parent to a
child and then there's some value
domains and these domains usually are
discrete so you have Abilene or some
kind of categorical variables but you
could also have continuous ones and I'll
show you a few examples of that as well
so so back to our confused students who
are how does it look like what we need
to describe for those arrows is
basically there's conditional mm-hmm
sorry probability distributions and I
have two tables there and as those two
tables are basically one way of
explaining the data that we saw mm-hmm
and the this way shows you basically
that if you are paying attention you
have much higher chance of being
confused and not not much but a little
bit higher chance of me giving a correct
answer so what we want to do is we want
to find the best Bayesian network given
a data and that's a that's a kind of a
plot that you see is taken from my
domain which is basically a lot of
microarray slides lined up sharing
expression for different genes and what
we need to do is we need to have a
scoring function that is giving us a
mathematical notion of which networks
are better than others and we want to
want those functions to be
to be basically additive with respect to
two different variables so we want to be
due to be able to compute it separately
so now this is tough
unfortunately the biggest problem in so
there's there's several ways of scoring
those networks I won't go into details
there's a lot of literature about that
but basically most of them are either
based on biostatistics or based on
hypothesis testing the bigger problem of
the so there's two problems with with
finding those networks one is that there
is a lot of potential parent sets but if
even a more difficult one is the fact
that there's we need to make sure that
there's no cycles in the result and in
order to deal with that we actually I
would like to focus on cases where this
is actually not an issue so one such
case is when you have a dynamic network
so so for example in in cases where
things are actually depending on of each
other in time so like mmm imagine that
the you have the three different
variables like for example I don't know
finding a new technology becoming
proficient with this technology that I'm
becoming bored with it and then finding
a new technology and so on and so forth
so that's the kind of the situation that
you might be familiar with and then you
have a the actual the actual network
resulting network of connections that is
sick there is there has a cycle and then
what you can do is you can represent
this with with different sets of
variables for a sort of before and after
the change in and then with with this
kind of so so that's the bottom graph
where you have basically
the temporal relationship unrolled and
then you need to supply for a training
of such a network you need to supply
pairs of observations of observation
before an observation after and that
breaks the cycles and allows you to mmm
allows you to to basically learn the
structure that has a cycle if you if you
then roll it back again so that's the
same network basically on both both
pictures another case there's quite
similar but it's even more important is
that sometimes you have different types
of variables so in this case which is a
little bit closer to home for me you
have mutations there are separate entity
you can have different pieces of parts
of your genome mutated or your patients
can have it and this can affect
expression of different proteins and
again this is a there's many proteins
and you can have many of them their
expression changed and then there's
diseases which again you could be
studying for example different subtypes
of the same disease or certain or
different spectrum of diseases and maybe
in many cases you would be interested
only in certain types of connections so
for example you may assume that you're
interested in which mutations cause
which changes and which changes in
expression cause different diseases and
not vice versa we know that it can be
vice versa so for example certain types
of cancer can and do cause disease
mutations or it but you might not you
might just for this purpose of building
this particular model you might not be
interested in that so that's kind of the
all about the introduction the very
basic stuff and then what we what we
developed a few years ago and now we're
we're further developing is basically
called a tool called being finder it's a
library it's a Python library open
source you can download it and it's it's
works in this very case
where you have a dataset a tabular data
set like like I showed you and it works
under the assumption that a circle isset
II is satisfied by a some external
constraint so basically either it's a
dynamic network or mm-hmm you have some
sort of constraint of the sort with this
mutation and and protein and disease
case it's relatively fast and it
actually finds the optimal solution so
how does it look like in an example the
simplest possible is basically we have
two two variables P 1 and P 2 together
there are there are so called regulators
in this case you can see it in the very
top this is the text file that is in an
input and you have this preamble with
hash there's a number of keywords you
can use regulators is just one and then
you have a tabular number of observation
this in this case it's it's inverted so
each column is actually an observation
in each row is a variable mmm and then
there's a common line version of the
tool so B and F is basically shorthand
for being finder and you can specify
that you want to use this file and then
it outputs the network that is
visualized at the bottom of this is done
with with the sight escape so that's
that's fairly easy you can do this
actually in parallel on number of a
number of course so that's very helpful
because when I said it's relatively
efficient it well for this particular
situation where you have six variables
it really is very fast but in cases
where you have let's say dozens of
variables and thousands of observation
it can already take hours on a single
CPU so then since our computers now have
multiple cores you can basically use
this minus K keyword parameter and then
basically it gives relatively good
efficiency so as you can see on the
graph with our current implementation
we had about half of the linear speed-up
when we're using multiple cores see
that's that's useful and and what I can
show you what I will show you now is a
few examples of a real-world
applications where we've used being
finer different in different settings so
so the first case is actually so that's
mostly for the that you don't really
have to get into details of that but
basically our collaborators found a way
of measuring histone modifications or
epigenetic modifications in in different
tissues and what you get the bought the
bottom part is the important part you
get these kind of data signals along the
chromosomes so so this is this is the
this is your signal and now they've
measured that for for a number of of
different modifications that you have
let me count one two three seven
different modifications and they all run
a long genome that's a genome of
actually fruit fly which is a very nice
model organism and then you you can see
that these profiles are kind of rough
that's that's the usual situation with
the experiment and what we want to find
is we want to find active regulatory
elements whatever that is what we would
like
what I can show you is here we have some
prior knowledge from from prior
experiments we have those blue and red
and black bars and you can see these are
regulatory elements that are either
active or inactive and our our point
here is to first learn the dependence or
conditional probability of a piece of
DNA being active or inactive based on
those profiles so what we need to first
find is is to find a we need to find a
training data set so a number of
examples where we actually know
what is the value of the variable that
we want to predict so so think luckily
we had those collaborators who could
have compiled this for us and they
they've basically built this matrix all
for example so so basically this is from
pictures of embryos with with staining
they have compiled this this database
and basically this this is our training
set so one important thing about this
you might might notice is that those
profiles are continuous or at least well
we could discretize this signal but it's
it's not clear how many levels of signal
you see there that was clearly there's
some higher level some low and there's
some different values in the middle it
might be different actually for
different different signals so one thing
being finder can do is it can handle
continuous data which is unusual for for
a Bayesian network software and and what
what it basically does is so here you
can have you can see an example of of an
of a network that uses this kind of data
for explanation so we have three
variables that are regulating the two
different outcomes and and they're all
continuous and in this case both of the
outputs actually depend on two different
variables and they depend in such a way
that it's not easy to predict from from
one so you can you can actually see the
on the bottom well bottom left part of
this right plot you see the the green
and I know how visible the colors are
you can see the green dots versus white
dots and this is the our Arab servation
sculler by the value of the X variable
and on the top right scatter plots you
see the values of Y variable depending
or
on the pairs of variables so you can see
that this this basically these are
Gaussian variables by the way and in in
this case what being finder does it
basically fits the best Gaussian
distributions that it can do it can find
for for those a B and C variables so
this is on the diagonal of the of this
matrix and substance subsequently once
once those those Gaussian normal
distributions are fitted it basically
takes the posterior problem the
probability of of each of those
observations to be in each of those each
of those observation to come from each
of the distribution so when you if you
if you see that the very bottom the C
variable is a very clean bimodal
distribution so basically you have two
very distinct populations so your you
have basically an underlying so it's
like a noisy generator you basically
have a discrete two states and if you're
in lower states like the yellow curve
basically you have some variability some
noise in observation but basically it's
you you can tell almost almost without
an error that you're actually in the
lower state and same for the right the
red distribution basically is the is the
excited high state or whatever you want
to call it and then it's it's quite
clear where you are it's more
interesting in Biore cases where the
where the distributions are kind of
getting closer to each other and there
you actually are taking advantage of
this probabilistic representation where
you basically see that there is a middle
ground there's a there's a place where
the probability of an observation in
this middle ground coming from either
active or inactive state is about the
same or but you can still see that this
this mixing is not you
so this usually you can tell that you're
well somewhere in the middle but more
like the the active state or more like
the inactive state so this basically the
nice part of a nice part of the of the
modeling framework is that it can take
advantage of this information so I could
discretize I could basically slash my
observations into lower and upper in
this point where the red and yellow
curves cross but I can actually take
advantage of of of this quantitative
information relative probability of
coming from each of the distribution so
how it works
basically what we did for this activity
yeah example this was used as a simple
classifier in the end you can see the
ROC curve and importantly for biologists
the model was actually quite intuitive
to interpret so you can see it on the
right there's you know six different
variables that seem to be important you
can actually quantify this relative
importance you can actually assign
positive or negative influence to each
variable and you can you can basically
use cross-validation to assess the
quality of this prediction the
prediction the the model itself actually
turns out to be the best model - turns
out to be only dependent on three
variables strong enough to to include
them and it's non lean it's it's non
additive so it's important if that that
this model could not be replaced by some
kind of linear regression based based
model well it provided some useful
predictions but I don't have much time
so I moved to another example so that's
how the input file would look like
there's a number that the the preamble
is much longer so you actually have
continuous so you need to say which
variables are continuous which are the
regulator's which can be perturbed and
then you can get so that's actually a
different data set that has
a continuous and perturbed so perturb
basically means that you can have mmm
things that are particularly useful for
for knockouts but are basically any any
variable that was in a particular
observation you don't want to learn from
this about this variable then you can
use this a more complex example now just
to get you even more confused as this
helps with comprehension as we've
learned in the beginning that there was
a case where we build a bigger model
where we had some missing data and we
actually use an expectation maximization
framework but the important idea is that
if you can basically construct the
multiple training data sets with with
different values for your variable and
then iterate until you converge and in
this case what I wanted to show you just
so that I actually do have a slide with
with actual code so that's taken from
from the from the paper from the
supplementary materials where we have a
code there's a red frame that's
basically that's that's how you prepare
the data it basically you have you can
select from from a matrix and then there
is a nice function that's called to be
NF which basically generates a nice data
set for for basically file like object
that that you can then use to create a
the proper data set and then you have
the function learn in a green frame
there's a it's a little bit long for
even the this screen
invocation of this function but it
basically has all the parameters this
needed and then you have the blue which
is basically saving the conditional
probability distribution with some again
with some parameters and then for
prediction you you do the data set very
similarly and then you use classifier
lists and then you get a list of class
of classification so that's that's
that's relatively simple I'd say and it
also helped us to to make these
predictions of of gene expression so in
summary what what I've told you is that
these fashion networks is a useful I
would argue mathematical model that can
give you predictive models based on
condition people using conditional
distribution probability distributions
it's open source and it's it's
relatively easy to apply to tabular data
it has a command-line tool and it can
use also as a library it handles
continuous data as well as the more
usual discrete and you can run it using
multi processing Python package with
relatively good efficiency and there's
some convenience function included like
like cross validation or RSC plots
that's included and there's a there's a
URL here and that that wouldn't be
that's not just me I've been working on
this for something like five years now
with with noir Belt who is my coworker
most recently aleena
frolova from from Kiev was working on
the new implementation of the
parallelization and she's trying so
we've been trying to make a cloud
version of that and we're I think we're
close to that parvo and Agnieszka were
involved earlier in making a second
second version of being finder that's
most suitable for classification and if
there's any questions I still have a few
minutes to
anza dem thank you very much so I was
wondering what kind of questions our
best sort of answered through this
verses you know all the other tools for
machine learning that we have so like
how does it work on high dimensional
data sets or is there some special use
we should really care about this for so
I would say that what we see from our
experience it's its most effective when
you have complex dependencies so so it
can be used for classification and it
has competitive
let's say competitive performance but it
really shines when you have complex
dependencies are not so many variables
because if you have really hundreds of
variables then it's gonna take long
unless you have thousands of course to
do to find the model it's also
relatively good if you have multiple so
so one nice thing it it works for
example if you have those kind of if if
your data is completely flat so you have
just hundreds of variables each one of
them the same and you just want to kind
of you know predict one other variable
from done then probably using random
forests or or as VMs is going to work
for you very well but if your data is
hierarchical so you have let's say
fifteen mutations hundred genes and then
three different disease variants that
you want to really predict from those
then you can use the Biogen networks
will it give you a benefit of actually
using some of the hierarchy of your of
your data and and in pretty and it's
also nice in a sense that it in the end
it it gives you this these connections
in an open sort of format so so in many
ways if you just use it for for
classification and if your data is not
particularly the dependencies are not
particularly complex so if this is
really a in the if the variable so for
example are independent and why don't
you use a knife bias classifier because
it makes the
sumption of Independence so if if if
it's satisfied and probably you'll get
the same thing with with naive bias for
example okay and I have a question over
here
I am using your library how how do you
avoid not confusing correlation with
causation well I'm not I mean it since
it's not really possible to to confuse
well to to kind of say well this is
really causal I mean unless you do
perturbation experiment and you actually
show that perturbing one you're actually
doing something to yes it's not really
excluding the possibility of the reverse
still being true right so so in in a way
what we are saying it was so so there
are other tools so I'd say there's a few
packages in our there's there's banjo
that's written in Java there's a number
of tools that let you find net the
Bayesian networks and one thing we're
doing here is kind of instead of trying
to to fight this problem of finding a
network that's I cyclic focus when when
this is really difficult computationally
we can focus on situations where we can
make constraints so for example I do
acknowledge maybe my diseases also
causing mutations for example but I'm
not gonna try to find these I'll assume
that I'm only interested in mutations
causing diseases for example right and
then using this framework can give me a
very flexible tool where I can have very
complex conditional dependencies in my
model in a relatively easy to comprehend
model because if I if I could use for
example in SVM with some kind of complex
kernel but then it's a it's a sort of a
black box tool that's very difficult to
to re reverse-engineer basically what is
this model actually using for example to
make a prediction and here it's actually
I didn't really talk about is but those
those scoring functions are usually
taking into account some kind of
sparsity of the model in one way or the
other so it's very different between
them how this is exactly achieved but
usually they're searching for a model
that is not taking all of the variables
because then they're very they're very
prone to overfitting I mean you could
make a budget Bayesian network from all
of your data with all of the variables
as parents of your single note that
you're interested in but then you'd most
likely over fit here to your data set so
those scoring functions will usually
take this into account and in the end
what what you get is is relatively
robust robust model and it's kind of
sparse usually yeah so you touched on
continuous and discrete variables but
how should we deal with sort of
categorical variables can we do that
within yeah yeah yeah that's the default
actually that's that by default it
basically it builds this kind of tables
can't kind of conditional probability is
basically a frequency table so like for
example this confused students or not so
so you have those those tables and they
grow naturally with the number of
parents they grow exponentially so
that's that's the only issue but that's
penalized in in a scoring function
usually and there's also one one
important thing is it when we were
developing this we we found it so
usually when people prove where we will
discuss the difficulty of problem of
finding the network the optimal network
it's usually done under the assumption
that you're dealing with the actual
probability distribution which is
usually not the case so usually you have
your thousand or ten thousand or million
observations and those observations
actually have a limited number of
limited information content so without
getting into much detail of of
information content this information
content of your data is providing you a
with a with an actual fixed limit on the
size of the network that can make the
can be bastard at some point you're
reaching the threshold where you are
actually adding too many parents to
basically justify explaining the
information in your
dataset so actually this is one nice
thing that is rarely done when you're
trying to find the best fitting model is
to basically limit in this case
basically it's it's it's inside the
scoring function to basically that there
is a limit on how big the model can grow
given the size of your input data so
perhaps I'm mistaken but it sounded like
you said with even dozens or hundreds of
features it could take hours to find the
optimal Bayesian network and if that's
the case how do you handle input with
millions of features I mean is there any
way you can sort of down sample or
aggregate those features like maybe if
it's labeled data split it using a
decision tree and then at each decision
level figure out how to merge multiple
features and then and then sort of have
like compound features that you're then
optimizing your Bayesian network on
would that give you the results would
that give you optimal results
essentially yeah so I guess the short
answer is that probably when you have
millions of features and most likely
biasing networks I mean at least today
like in in a vanilla flavor of Bayesian
errors it's probably not the tool you
want to use because it's naturally you
are considering a number of subsets of
your millions of variables so even if
your subsets of two that's quite a lot
to look at so I'd say that yes most
likely you could if you have some way of
in an organized way sub sampling or your
features I mean I think that yeah
probably you'd be better off using some
other tools that are basically targeted
aimed at this kind of a situation and
then maybe you could so I guess you
could use something for feature
selection or some kind of removing the
features that are clearly not related to
to the variable that you're most
interested in in explaining and then use
Bayesian networks to mind this limited
set of features so that's what I would
do so use something for like random
forests to to weed out those
variables that are really not in putting
anything and then kind of you have your
a few dozens of potentially important
things to get the really complex
conditional probability distribution
from them all right so let's give a
round of applause to Bartek